el parlamento de israel dio el primer
paso hacia su disolución al aprobar en
una lectura preliminar el proyecto de
ley que conduciría al estado hebreo o
unas quintas elecciones en tres años y
medio la propuesta votada en la que
necesita nuestras espaldas fue apoyada
por 110 de 120 legisladores no obstante
para que la disolución se formaliza el
texto deberá pasar otras tres lecturas
en un proceso que se completaría la
próxima semana el proyecto ahora está en
manos del comité de la que knesset que
tendrá que decidir si continúa con el
trámite o lo deriva el comité legal la
duda y es sin mirar back parlamentario
que renunció a la coalición webber
gobernante y que encabeza el comité de
la que n se puede llegar a retrasar las
votaciones con el fin de dar margen a
que se forme un gobierno alternativo en
el actual parlamento algo que parece
poco probable pero que ha devuelto al ex
primer ministro benjamin netanyahu al
centro de la esfera política israelí
cuatro encuestas sobre unos posibles
comicios dan como favorito al partido
likud de netanyahu que mejoraría su
resultado en comparación al de 2021 pero
no obstante su bloque de derecha y ultra
religioso judío anual haría la mayoría
de 61 escaños para gobernar a menos que
cambien las actuales alianzas políticas
del mismo modo tampoco le darían los
números a la coalición gobernante de
naftalí bennett y yair lapid que ya han
visto colapsar una formación
experimental con políticos de
centro-derecha ultra derecha
socialdemócratas izquierda y también
árabes lo que demuestra que israel se
arriesga a seguir en este estancamiento
político que perdura desde 2019